selling homemade baked goods is not a
piece of cake in New Jersey you could
say home bakers in that state are now
suing the government over a law that
bans the sale of items not made in a
commercial grade kitchen New Jersey is
the only state in this country where
home bakers can sell treats for charity
but not for profit meg Oliver spoke to
one baker to learn how selling her
kitchen creations could help bring in
some much-needed cash meg good morning
good morning the ability to sell baked
goods could be an added financial boost
for home bakers but they face potential
fines if they break the law a state
senator stands by the ban of selling
homemade baked goods because he says
it's in the public's best taste and
you're known for these cake pops right
yes I am yeah it's something I never
expected that would happen Heather o
Cinco started baking about ten years ago
for her son's school activities she had
no idea her sweet skills would turn into
a recipe for requests I was doing them
for sports and then family and friends
it just kind of caught on the good thing
about making cake pops is you always
smell like chocolate
the single mother in New Jersey lives
paycheck to paycheck her chocolate
coated cake pops were so popular she
started selling them for extra dough but
she quickly learned it was illegal what
was your reaction when you found out it
was illegal to sell cake pops it was
crushing because I always wanted to have
my own business I believe in creating
your own destiny and being
self-sufficient New Jersey is the only
state that bans the sale of home baked
goods for profit earlier this year a
judge in Wisconsin ruled the ban there
unconstitutional leaving New Jersey as
the only holdout earlier this month a
group of home bakers filed a civil suit
against the New Jersey Department of
Health claiming the ban on home bake
good sales violates the state's
Constitution how much could you make
selling cake pops I would probably ask
me twenty to thirty thousand a year and
how would that affect your bottom line
oh my gosh it would be amazing
bakers can sell their treats if they
have a commercial license which requires
the use of a commercial-grade kitchen
outside of the home renting a kitchen
can cause thousands of dollars
year home bakers have been lobbying the
state legislature for nearly a decade to
change that Erika Smith is their
attorney the Baker's here they didn't
just jump and file a lawsuit they have
been fighting for 10 years to get this
law passed in the legislature and one
man has stood in the way senator Vitali
I'm just asking that there be some level
of inspection to ensure that certain
public health standards are met state
senator Jo by tally is the chairman of
the Senate Health Committee so this
isn't about competition for you your big
concern is health
I've spoken with Baker's in bakeries and
they said we don't care and that's not
my concern this is a business model and
it doesn't really talk about liability
insurance and what if you make something
and someone gets sick or you leave a
toothpick in it the New Jersey
Department of Health said it does not
comment on pending litigation Racine Co
says if the law were overturned she'd
start selling as soon as possible she
says the extra cash would allow her to
set up a college fund for her son and
eventually be able to open up her own
storefront and she has said that she
would open up her kitchen any day of the
week for an inspection
$1,000 that's a lot of cake pops that's
a lot of Shenko needs to send senator
vitality some cake pops yeah they're
pretty good yeah they're pretty good and
what he's talking about could happen
anywhere you know in terms of yeah
she should they should be allowed to set
up the business she can now set up a
pass-through business and he'll only
have to pay 21 percent in taxes there
you go working further all right Meg
thank you so much